one of the aspects missing in podcasts
and in this space in general is an
emphasis on the papers themselves sure
you have these four hour brobda nagyan
podcast where we go into extreme depth
minute detail however what we'd like to
do is every day even if you're not
interested in the podcast per se you'll
get a new paper 60 seconds covering a
new paper explaining the key ideas in
relatively rudimentary terms for
instance coming up will be one of the
papers that got Ed Whitson the fields
met a second one will be on Michael
Levin about morphogenesis we want to
cover other papers that are obscure that
would be seminal had more people known
about them this will serve as an
introduction thus every day for 60
seconds you'll get a Sleek new article a
new paper subscribing to toe not only
gives you podcasts but will be
supplementing that with actual hard
equations and data and charts the plan
is to have these papers longer and
longer so longer than 60 seconds while
keeping it compendious much like two
minute papers except for math
Consciousness physics philosophy
Neuroscience the themes of this channel
thank you so much this is going to be a
great deal of fun